Saturn's moon Titan has fascinated astronomers
for quite some time.
Now this little world has thrown us a curveball
-- it might be older than Saturn itself!
Hello everyone, I'm Ian O'Neill, space producer
for Discovery News and I want to talk about
one of the weirdest moons ever studied.
According to most prediction models, moons
are formed from the same material as the planets
they orbit.
In other words, the planet comes first, then
the moon.
But a new finding about Saturn's moon Titan
seems to contradict that model.
NASA's Cassini spacecraft recently beamed
back some bizarre isotopic data about Titan's
atmosphere.
All elements have a certain number of isotopes,
which means the same element can have a different
number of neutrons but the same number of
protons in the nucleus.
Titan's atmosphere is rich in Nitrogen, so
researchers can get a good idea of its origins
by measuring the quantities of Nitrogen-14
and Nitrogen-15.
Any changes in the ratio between these two
isotopes can help scientists decipher how
old the atmosphere is and its possible origin.
And this is the strange thing: the isotopic
ratio shows Titan's atmosphere has similar
characteristics to the ancient comets that
formed in the outer solar system, over 4 billion
years ago.
This study provides a hint that Titan's building
blocks didn't form from the hot gases that
created Saturn, it's actually composed of
ancient ices, pre-dating Saturn!
There is also an implication for Earth.
It has always been assumed that the majority
of Nitrogen in OUR atmosphere was deposited
by asteroid and comet impacts.
Our planet's atmosphere is also Nitrogen rich,
and maybe some of it comes from the same ancient
material as Titan's.
Of course, this isn't the only thing that
makes Titan a bit strange.
It's also the only moon in the entire solar
system to have a thick and dynamic coat of
gas with a surface pressure about 60 percent
higher than Earth's.
There are large 'seas' of liquid methane and
ethane and these organic compounds have their
own cycles through Titan's atmosphere, much
like Earth's water cycle.
Methane RAIN has also been spotted, which
is pretty alien to us Earthlings.
Titan is also rich in organic compounds on
its surface -- hydrocarbons cover the moon,
leading many astrobiologists to believe it
is similar to Earth when it was very young.
The building blocks of life are in abundance,
motivating scientists to push for another
surface mission.
The European Space Agency did one in 2005,
called Huygens.
The robotic lander was attached to the Cassini
spacecraft that orbits the ringed gas giant
to this day.
Huygens beamed back photographs revealing
a pebbly world covered with river channels,
dunes and valleys.
So the finding that the building blocks of
Titan may be older than Saturn itself only
adds to the fascinating science surrounding
it -- fascination that can only be satisfied
when we land another mission onto the moon's
surface, or -- my PERSONAL favorite -- send
a probe to sail in one of Titan's seas.
What about you- are you eager to find out
more about Titan?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back for new DNews videos every day
of the week.